mon pronostic pour dimanche messieurs
3 030 pour qu'ils vont ringard lorraine
et vous mâcher rennes fer renfe a
combien de zéros pourquoi on dit sa
chance oui et vous ou de 20,2 en faveur
des magistrats quand est ce que le match
l'édition d'imagés à terrell leyio lyon
et la finale de la coupe
en tout cas je souhaite que ce soit à
rennes parce que rennes s'est montré
quand même
c'est bien défendu avec marseille sa
chance continue la sirène tous les
gagner je serais content je me souviens
de lui succéder il ya 45 ans salut du
110m orange gagnent à 1,0 monsieur et
pour dieu bah je pense que rennes gagne
radar quoi sur moi et mes qualités j'ai
vu certainement au jeu donnera une
gagnant 2 à 0 j'espère qu'ils gagneront
c'est tout
lyon ou rennes rennes rennes dessus je
vois la victoire de l'arène par un but
d'écart
le mulet car oui pourquoi vu ça sera dur
ce sera très difficile je pense oui je
pense que les attaques de lions et plus
dynamique et plus meurtrière que celle
de rennes et d'autres cas il faut quand
même compter sur la joie de vivre de
rennes
oui bien sûr ça on peut pas oublier ça
quand même c'était quelque chose
d'extraordinaire pour vous c'est l'un
des plus beaux souvenirs de votre
carrière carrière de sportif bien sûr
c'était l'apothéose d'ailleurs puisque
par la suite je suis resté encore sur la
scène deux ou trois ans puis je suis
parti discrètement alors c'était
vraiment
été bénéfique et le dimanche ses joueurs
doivent présenter leurs meilleures
conditions je pense que vous avez voulu
les réunir ici à saint malo pour leur
éviter un petit peu les tracas de la
ville de rennes car ça bouge on parle
essentiellement de labeur sans pareil à
rennes
ne serait-ce que la chasse aux billets
tous les joueurs sont sollicités pour
les voir les toucher
je pense que d'être ici nous sommes un
peu quand même
quelles sont les chances du starman à
votre avis c'est bien que cette équipe
lyonnaise
besson
certaines décembre laissant sans gagner
ce match là on n'a pas tous les sens
bien sûr parce qu'une finale n'est
jamais joué d'avancé
lyon aussi défendre chèrement sa peau je
pense que ce sera un bon match parce que
là il n'est pas question de vouloir
défendre pour l'une ou l'autre équipe
aux commandes et il faut gagner
je pense que ça devrait être un bon
match et on a au moins autant de chances
que lui aussi non plus
plein de confiture que chose
extraordinaire et je crois que c'est un
être encore plus vos parce que on
connaît l'ambiance on sait ce que ça
représente vraiment content d'être plus
beau encore que en 65 ans ou plus au
sport qui je donne lors quelles sont les
chances du sahara n'est pas très bien
autant de chances que lyon sur une sur
un match en finale je crois que de
l'hérault homme qui se présente de
chaque côté sont survoltés et voilà tout
prix gagner
est ce que le trac et joue un rôle
important le trac fou et puis également
la chaleur parce que ça fait deux mois
qu'on ne joue plus en diurne sans deux
éléments qui vont certainement
intervenir tout au moins au début de
match là vous êtes confiant quand même
oui bien sûr confiant mais sérieux pense
que tout le monde est un peu de
confiance aux tous les spectateurs les
supporters mais je pense que les joueurs
ont trop conscient de l'image qu'ils ont
réalisé la vente non c'est surtout les
supporters qui sont trop confiance moi
mais parce qu'il faut bien dire les
reliques finale de la coupe et vous le
savez vous par expérience c'est quand
même pas le même match que les autres
dans un match très difficile
je pense qu'il nous prendrons pas si en
cas d'échec
c'est inédit
tine baun qui au départ autant de
chances que nous avec des armes un petit
peu différente
s'appuie surtout sur une bonne défense
mais que l'huile à novik et paysages
sont plus dans l'axé central
et puis devant et bien il y a
lorsque les à edina l'eau qui à tout
moment sont capables de faire ici pas de
manière vous pensé très très
vraisemblablement que ça sera un match
équilibré
oui la seule chose je pense que si on
est mené à marcq on a plus de
possibilité de revenir que pense que si
on marque les premiers on gagnera
sûrement
le sentiment d'avoir un compromis un
contrat bien remplie grâce d'ailleurs
comité de gestion entraîneurs et aux
dirigeants et sans oublier le public
le public a joué un grand rôle vous
pensez le public algérien grand rôle et
je puis dire que je suis vraiment
content de la façon il ay la
privatisation a opéré le jour de la
demi-finale et l'ambiance qui règne en
ce moment ci à la veille de la finale
à votre avis est-ce que ce public à
colombes jouera un rôle déterminant
il a su persuader oui si la même
ambiance que pour la demi finale
oui certainement il joue un grand rôle
et je compte bien ça ce que bic qui
préside l